recordemos lo que vimos en el vídeo
anterior teníamos un banco
que tiene un bien el cual fue comprado
originalmente por 100 dólares tiene 60
dólares en obligaciones
y 40 dólares de equilibrio y estos son
los bienes tóxicos y en este ejemplo
simplificado solo hay un bien el
problema establecido al inicio de la
crisis de los bancos es que los bancos
no pueden vender estos bienes para pagar
sus deudas por el precio en el que ellos
quieren venderlos ya que si los bancos
venden esto por menos de 60 dólares el
banco se irá a la bancarrota así que
aquí el banco lo quiere vender por 60
dólares o más mientras que el mercado
está dispuesto a pagar 30 dólares o
menos
por dichos bienes por lo que si el banco
vendiera esto en el mercado sólo
obtendría esos 30 dólares entonces sus
obligaciones serían mucho mayores que
sus bienes y el banco se iría a
bancarrota y como mencionamos al final
del vídeo anterior la circunstancia
actual es que tenemos una inversionista
privado aunque aquí los números son un
poquito diferentes a los del vídeo
anterior tenemos 5 dólares de un
inversionista privado
tenemos 5 dólares del tesoro y esto es
solo un resumen del vídeo anterior
estos son los inversionistas del
equilibrio y tenemos 50 dólares que
fueron prestados por parte de la reserva
federal
y esos números fueron modificados para
que se ajusten adecuadamente a la
cantidad que se quiere pagar por los
bienes del banco en total tenemos 50
dólares que fueron prestados por la
reserva federal y esta entidad tendrá 60
dólares en total al ser capitalizada y
ahora lo que pueden hacer es darle estos
60 dólares al banco especialmente
pagando el precio que están pidiendo los
bancos para vender sus bienes así que el
banco les da estos bienes y ahora tendrá
el banco 60 dólares en efectivo que
puede usar para mantener sus
obligaciones líquidas y ahora esta otra
entidad tendrá el bien tóxico y
mencionamos en el vídeo anterior porque
un inversionista pensaría o consideraría
hacer esto ellos obtienen un beneficio
desproporcionado en el caso optimista de
que el bien resulte que valga más de lo
que fue pagado en el caso hipotético de
que esté bien terminará valiendo unos
100 dólares y se le deben 50 dólares a
la reserva federal
qué es este préstamo de aquí y van a
repartir en partes iguales el equilibrio
el tesoro y el inversionista privada
cuál es el equilibrio que queda nos
quedan 50 dólares en equilibrio que se
reparten equitativamente le tocan 25
dólares al tesoro y 25 dólares al
inversionista privado así que si su
inversión inicial fue de 5 dólares
recibió 25 dólares
que es excelente cinco veces la cantidad
que invirtió pero en el caso negativo
pues el caso negativo es imaginarse que
esté bien tóxico realmente vale 30
dólares vamos a dibujarlo y continuamos
con el resumen de lo que vimos en el
vídeo anterior lo que es importante
tener muy claro ya que nos va a ayudar a
comprender lo que podría suceder así que
este es el punto de vista optimista
y aquí abajo está el punto de vista
pesimista entonces estos bienes resulta
que sí valen 30 dólares
tenemos el préstamo de 50 dólares de
fair
no nos queda nada de equilibrio por lo
que va a tener la pérdida de su préstamo
pero el inversionista privado ya que no
hay equilibrio restante no va a recibir
nada así que se pasó de cinco dólares a
cero dólares pero esto sigue pareciendo
un buen riesgo dependiendo de como
consideren sus probabilidades si algunas
personas pensarán que hay la misma
probabilidad de que esto ocurra a que
esto otro ocurra pues valdría la pena
tomar el riesgo si se tiene el 50 por
ciento de probabilidad de recibir cinco
veces el dinero que se invierte y hay un
50 por ciento de probabilidad de que se
pierda ese dinero pues el valor esperado
aquí punto 5 por 25 más punto 5 por ser
tendremos un valor esperado de 12
dólares por lo que yo sí pagaría 5
dólares por algo que tiene un valor
esperado de 12 dólares es un buen
beneficio recibiremos el 140 por ciento
del dinero invertido y no se ven
beneficios hacia a diario
desafortunadamente la probabilidad de
que estas cosas sucedan no es del 50%
cada una ya que vemos que el mercado
actualmente está dispuesto a pagar sólo
30 dólares por estos bienes si estas
personas consideraran que hay una
posibilidad de que esto valiera más de
los 60 dólares cualquier posibilidad
ellos estarían dispuestos a pagar un
poco más por ellos ellos estarían
dispuestos a pagar un poco más de 30
dólares por ellos pero ya que estamos
viendo la situación del mercado actual
antes de que intervenga el gobierno
claramente nadie piensa que esto vale
más de 30 dólares por lo que es mucho
más probable que ocurra este escenario
que este otro pueden hacer una hoja de
cálculo y sopesar estas probabilidades y
si hacen que esta probabilidad sea más
alta que esta otra entonces el valor
esperado seguirá siendo menor a 5
dólares y se espera que se pierda dinero
por lo que diríamos bueno quién pensaría
si quiere hacer esto aunque de parte del
gobierno nos digan que esto es una
cuestión cara yo gano cruz tú pierdes
ya que en el escenario positiva el
inversionista privado obtiene la mayor
parte de la ganancia junto con el tesoro
mientras que la reserva federal sólo
obtiene la devolución de su préstamo con
una tasa de interés muy baja mientras
que en el escenario negativo la mayor
parte del golpe va a ser recibido por la
reserva federal con su préstamo y
después el tesoro ya que invertido de
igual manera que el inversionista
privada así que esta es una de las cosas
que se ofrecen como incentivo para
participar en esto pero lo que yo
comento es que aún cuando esté esta
posibilidad de una ganancia
desproporcionada una inversionista
inteligente no se va a dejar seducir por
esto no querrá invertir ya que sigue
dándose cuenta de que esto no vale lo
que se estaría pagando por ello así que
la pregunta es quién va a participar en
esto y esto es lo que les mencionaba en
el vídeo anterior que podría parecerles
perturbador la cuestión obvia aquí es
que los bancos quieran comprarse a ellos
mismos vamos a dibujar esta situación
porque es importante que ustedes lo
comprendan y francamente yo no sé cómo
se pueda evitar que esto suceda
si es que
sucede esta versión del plan de snr esta
es la hoja de balance de los bancos o
del banco su hoja de balance del antes
en el que pagaron 100 dólares por estos
bienes tienen 60 dólares de obligaciones
en préstamos depósitos etcétera
originalmente tenían 40 dólares de
equilibrio lo que hace el banco es que
va a tomar cierto dinero extra y no hay
problema para que consigan ese dinero
extra de hecho el gobierno les está
haciendo préstamos en este momento así
que lo que se hace es tomar prestados un
digamos que es 7 dólares del gobierno y
como les comento esto está sucediendo no
es nada de ficción por lo que aquí se
tienen 7 dólares en efectivo lo que es
el banco es crear una entidad separada
que la pueden llamar como ellos quieran
ponerla en un fondo de cobertura y de
hecho estas cosas suceden todo el tiempo
no hay algo que evite que ocurra esto de
poner esos siete dólares en otra entidad
de la cual el banco es dueño de su
equilibrio este efectivo va para acá y
después toman estos siete dólares
esto para participar en este plan en
este nuevo plan de geithner así que el
banco toma estos siete dólares que bien
pudo haberlos tomado prestados del
gobierno participa en el plan como el
inversionista privado y lo pongo aquí
entre comillas y aquí pueden poner
varias capas incluso podrían pedir a
algunos de sus fondos de cobertura que
son clientes de ellos que hagan esto hay
muchísimas formas de hacer esto por lo
que yo creo que es virtualmente
imposible evitarlo o hacer una
legislación que prevenga esto así que
hacen esto
el tesoro participa con la misma
cantidad de inversión otros siete
dólares como inversionista del
equilibrio y después se toman prestados
86 dólares de la reserva federal
esto fue del tesoro y ahora el banco es
el inversionista privada controla esta
entidad de aquí o controla a quien
controla esta entidad esto no importa
pero ellos esencialmente establecen el
precio por el cual se va a comprar este
bien tóxico que vienen siendo sus
propios bienes por lo que pueden pagar
100 dólares por esto aun cuando no lo
valga y todo mundo sepa que estas cosas
no valen nada así que pagan 100 dólares
por esto lo quitan de su hoja de balance
se quedan con 100 dólares de efectivo
y aquí se queda el bien tóxico porque
haría esto el banco piensen en ello un
momento en esta realidad antes de que
todo esto suceda este banco tiene un 100
por ciento de exposición a este bien
tóxico tiene todo esto de aquí a lo que
está expuesto y por lo que sabemos sólo
valen 30 dólares pero el banco nunca
quiere aceptar esta realidad mientras
que en esta otra realidad el banco sólo
tiene una exposición de 7 dólares aún
cuando esta cosa termine muy mal
quién va a recibir la pérdida entonces
el banco solo tendrá una pérdida de
siete dólares y el resto de la pérdida
irá a los contribuyentes al tesoro y la
reserva federal así que esta situación
es excelente para los bancos en esta
realidad cuando hay un problema el bien
solo vale 30 dólares por lo que la
pérdida del banco es de 70 dólares
mientras que en esta otra realidad si
esté bien tóxico solo vale 30 dólares el
banco solo tendrá una pérdida de 7
dólares y el banco permanecerá solvente
y esta inversión de aquí se va a
desaparecer pero aún así el banco tendrá
a 100 dólares en efectivo así que lo que
no es que y ya que francamente no hay
nada que lo evite es casi algo que
seguramente va a ocurrir tenemos esta
gran pregunta porque un inversionista
privado consideraría participar en esto
aún cuando el gobierno te esté dando una
mayor proporción de los beneficios y no
tanto con las pérdidas de todas maneras
no se participaría si se tiene la
convicción de que el escenario negativo
es el que tiene más probabilidades de
ocurrir pero si se participaría en ello
si ustedes mismos fueran los mismos
vendedores de este bien tóxico ya que si
ustedes son el banco pasarían de una
exposición de 100 dólares o de una
exposición del 100 por ciento a una
exposición del 7 por ciento de siete
dólares en este caso y permanecerán
solventes pero el efecto neto de esto en
este caso el banco tiene 100 dólares
bueno de hecho tienen 93 porque usaron 7
dólares para esto pero ellos reciben 100
dólares por lo que gastan 93 dólares por
algo que realmente vale 30 dólares
así que la diferencia estos 63 dólares
son esencialmente un cheque que está
siendo escrito por la reserva federal y
el tesoro para estos bancos y aquí no
estamos hablando realmente de sólo 63
dólares la magnitud es enorme serían de
alrededor de 6 billones de dólares por
lo que a mí me resulta algo perverso ya
que con esto básicamente se está
recapitalizando a los bancos mientras
que estos bancos hacen a un lado a sus
inversionistas en lugar de que este
cheque por 6 billones de dólares cede a
los inversionistas que están teniendo
las pérdidas con estos bancos se está
recapitalizando al banco que cometió el
error en primer lugar y hay otro vídeo
en donde mencionó una posible solución
donde aquí no se dé este dinero a los
bancos en problemas sino a un sistema
que esté libre de estos bienes tóxicos
que tendrá todos los beneficios para
solucionar esto y evitar darles esta
enorme cantidad de dinero a las personas
que nos metieron en problemas desde el
comienzo espero que hayan comprendido
esto ya que a mí realmente me inquieta
mucho y nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo